tents go up in the Syrian town of dinar
now a temporary home for families with
nowhere else to go they fled maarat
al-nouman in the south of eid lib
province as syrian government forces
advanced many leaving most of their
belongings behind
we fled from the bombardment and came
here it's a small camp that doesn't
really fit a lot of people and the
people just keep coming the situation is
hard since the start of December nearly
two hundred and fifty thousand people
have been displaced from Italy the last
rebel-held area of Syria most are women
and children many have fled by Road for
others fuel shortages have stopped them
from getting away some are trying to
seek shelter in Turkey but they're not
being allowed to cross the border this
comes on top of the displacement figures
that we had from the end of April to the
end of August where more than 400,000
people have been displaced so what we
have is a displacement crisis on top of
another displacement crisis President
Bashar al-assad has vowed to recapture
rebel-held areas showing an airstrikes
backed by Russia have intensified
forcing aid agencies to suspend
operations in the area unless the
fighting ends there are fears that the
supply of humanitarian aid will stop as
soon as next month in my mind it's
neither the Russians nor the Turks that
are the key to the solution the key to
the solution is the international
community getting involved in this and
putting pressure both on the Syrian
regime in Russia and Turkey for a
resolution that doesn't cause massive
human loss of life or a humanitarian
catastrophe
the violence goes against an August
ceasefire deal and international calls
for a de-escalation but the Syrian
government says recapturing the province
is just a matter of time
Nicola gage al Jazeera